has not replied to anybody did they ever
get back to you no I think we're going
to sue them
um
you know normally you never say these
things like you just filed but we're in
a different kind of political landscape
and cultural landscape so I think the
current plan is we're exploring a crowd
fund and potential class action I think
you know for us timcast music had
probably 25
000 sales and uh through band camp it
might be like 10 000 or something so
it's ten thousand people well the issue
and then you've got then you've got five
times August Bryce and Bryson gray
Bryson gray mentioned he was banned as
well I don't know why they've given us
no reason they have an absolute
termination Clause but I'm not sure that
matters for the people who purchase the
product they can no longer get access to
they can't yeah so the idea right now is
I'm talking with a prominent uh lawyer
on censorship issues and I said I you
know what do you think breach of
contract we've got customers who can no
longer access the product they've paid
for and we have no vehicle by which to
refund them because it went through
bandcampment bandcamp terminated our
accounts without notice so there's a
there's a problem right here now people
like hey I bought a song I can't get it
okay and uh it just breach of contract
that sounds like it for sure so they
have an absolute termination Clause they
say like we can ban for whatever reason
but that might not actually hold up in
court you can say whatever you want
doesn't mean anything so what about for
the users to pay the money well exactly
right so they still have accounts
they're still expecting to get what they
paid for and they have no access to it
so the accountant our account needs to
exist isn't this what happened they can
make an argument that we can't upload
Twitter control it but they the people
who bought the music still need to be
able to get it so long story short the
general idea is going to be to create a
crowd fund that would go directly to the
legal team not to anyone else involved
for the purpose of the of defending this
upwards of enemy I'd imagine probably
going to be in the 20.
in people right it could be a class
action suit because you've got Bryson
Gray's fans I haven't talked to any of
these people but Bryson gray five times
August and Tim cast the combined fan
bases who purchased music through that
platform it's going to be in the tens of
thousands isn't this it's gonna be a
huge lawsuit isn't this similar to what
they did at patreon
yeah this was this was the this was the
the Owen Benjamin lawsuit yeah and there
was uh uh so so we'll see here's the
thing I don't know I I personally feel
that they have they have breached
contract between the customers between
us they've done it for uh uh unjust
reasons that they they can we can do
whatever we want whenever we want but
like
you I I I'm not sure that's true so what
we're going to do is we're going to they
could say what it is and they haven't
and I think it's simply put you know
you'll often hear from lawyers they'll
say something like there's no point in
filing the lawsuit because you won't win
anyway blah blah blah well that's not
what we're hearing now what we're
hearing now from these teams is we
actually need to pursue this stuff to
figure out what the precedent is on this
kind of bridge of contract but we need
the money for it so I said okay what if
we did a crowd fund and then we just got
I don't know what if we got a million
people to give 10 bucks and just put 10
million bucks in the coffers of a legal
firm to oh that'd be nice they could do
a lot with that well they could we could
then truly figure out if these companies
are are truly uh engaging in you know
civil tour violations or whatever and
then we we could actually get some
judges to issue rulings on whether or
not they are allowed to do these things
and I'll put it this way the left wants
to Sue that Baker in Colorado into
Oblivion and they keep doing it yeah I'm
down to play the same game I I'm pretty
confident that between all of the follow
the followers that I the daily wire
anybody else has post-millennial they'd
be willing to pitch in 10 bucks to a law
firm none of us will go anywhere near
that one throw 10 bucks in for that and
then like a law firm just explore
anti-censorship lawsuits that would be
amazing so I was talking we'll see where
it goes five times August too and he
started doing some digging into who the
people are that work at bandcamp and
it's a whole bunch of pronouns in BIOS
doofuses
who are making these decisions big
shocker which is exactly what we found
out at Twitter that it was all these
contractors these like third-party
Contracting you know trans activists who
were like I don't care about any of that
you can't say that that has no bearing
whatsoever on my contract with a company
and the customers oh I agree and and
that so they can believe whatever they
want to believe and maybe the reason
they took us down is political all I'm
saying is I think we need to have a
judge issue a ruling on this and it
could be simple maybe we issue a a
initial you know filing and then the
judge says no look their terms clearly
outlined your agreement sorry have a
nice day okay well now here's John Smith
who purchased a song and can't get it he
has a lawsuit oh by the way here's Jane
Smith she purchased a song they're all
she has a lawsuit every single
individual who now has no access to a
thing they paid for and we have no
vehicle to refund their money anyway
well we got to figure this out so I'm
thinking we get 10 million dollars to a
law firm have them start filing away I
don't I don't know if class action
necessarily is the right approach I
don't know the rules sometimes they
force a class action I think the
appropriate thing is that some people
gave different amounts of money so
because you could give as much money as
you wanted so maybe the the best
approach is to have a bunch of
individual plaintiffs maybe three
thousand lost lawsuits filed all at once
at you know just there you go and then
we'll figure out what the uh let me just
go from there yeah yeah so we'll see
though we haven't done anything yet uh
I'm talking to a lawyer and it's
seems like there's like what you're
saying you don't want to just you don't
want to just make videos complaining
about the double standards you actually
want to do something and take it well
there's there's some other big news
coming up crazy that's crazy you know
we're going to do that we're going to do
a show on one of our culture war
episodes which is the Friday morning
show at youtube.com timcast
and uh there's gonna be a big announce
coming soon about the efforts we're
taking in defense of free speech so stay
tuned for that uh and then there's this
one which I think we we've just got we
we can't keep falling on well you know
it'll cost too much money so there's no
point in trying it's like well look I
think they breached their contract so
let's at least have a judge decide
that's what that's the point right and
even though you're you're costing them
time you're costing them effort nothing
like that nothing like that if the judge
came out in two seconds and said yes or
no I'd be satisfied the question is we
have not gotten definitive answers
because whenever it comes to some kind
of censorship case lawyers always say
it'll be too expensive it's not worth it
you lose and I'm like okay well can we
at least try look there's no point okay
what if we got a crowdfund together well
it depends on what your goal is the goal
is to to hammer out definitively what
are the rules right so then there is a
point because a baker can't can't you
know is forced to bake a cake or
whatever and they keep suing them
non-stop that is insane but then at the
same time the left says we can ban you
but you can't ban us I'm like okay let's
just stop arguing about it and have a
judge decide which is importantly
different argument because I was gonna
say because in in all of those instances
how many bakeries did you drive past
before you found that one Bakery there's
bakeries in every single town with the
internet and the way that it's set up in
many of these cases you have monopolies
you have many natural monopolies and
this is a fundamentally different
situation that's why Elon buying Twitter
is so important because there is only
one Twitter I I have truth I have getter
I have telegram but you know what
Twitter is Twitter and Twitter and No
One's Gonna knock that off this is the
fundamental difference and this is why
you can't apply the same logic because
it is Apples oranges yeah and it's
interesting too with the left because
they're perfectly comfortable censoring
books censoring RL Stein censoring Roald
Dahl but they refuse to allow
conservatives to take porn out of school
we just had an entire hearing with taibi
and shellenberger it shows exactly how
willing there and this is a very huge
difference between the left and the
right in this country is the left has
moral Clarity and the right is scared to
argue from a position of this is good
for society well and we see this all
over the place we see this like well we
have to be a little more nuanced about
it and perhaps and it's like no I kind
of am done with that it's it's it's
ridiculous no it's you always want to
play they always want to play Within the
left frame they always want to use
liberal frame they want to say well use
the same stupid language the same the
same language that we're going to argue
about well I heard that one is this
freedom is that freedom so I'm going to
use it just just stop stop apologizing
for Western Civilization stop
apologizing Western Civilization is the
best civilization it's amazing by the
way it's the reason we don't have child
sacrifices to the the you know the sun
god anymore okay so I don't know the sun
god seems pretty pissed off lately we
didn't have winter this this year you
know so maybe some place had a pretty
bad winter though some Colorado got hit
we didn't get anything we had no snow at
all my son was asking me that he was
like he was like Daddy when is it going
to snow because I want to make a snowman
you had no snow well I mean I'm only
about an hour from here so yeah we had I
mean flurries that's it I went
snowboarding and it was a brown mountain
with white strips going down it from the
snow machines did you go up in PA no we
went to uh Timberline okay because we we
drove up HPA we drove up to PA a couple
of times and it's exactly like that
there's uh there's white tail in PA I
think it's in PA yeah there's white tail
there's there's liberty there's Round
Top yeah yeah and it's like you'll be
driving through mud and then yeah it's
like mud mud mud mud mud snow but cool
cool thing though is and Olivia I know I
sent you the videos of this we actually
got four-year-old Jack Jack up on skis
for the very first time I know he and
his brother AJ are watching so Jack Jack
you did a great job skiing buddy
remember French Pizza french fries Pizza
in that uh that beaver look at his
shadow and it was supposed to be winter
for a long time or something like that I
don't remember no I think that was Pete
bootage
unfortunately it wasn't a shadow it was
the shadow of another derailed train it
was it was it wasn't his Shadows
it was The Toxic smoke that blocking out
the sun because he signed off on a
chemical attack on the Midwest and the
people who lived there because they
voted for Donald Trump and he said oh
don't worry about that we're totally
fine if you and your progeny die out
because we don't want you anymore yeah
yeah they definitely don't yeah well I
think in terms of uh
culture War issues there's there's a
couple things that need to happen and
making culture is one of the most
important things and then
lawsuits because the left is doing
lawsuits left and right of course the
right has like some sometimes the right
will sit there and complain about Mark
Elias and I and I sit there and go well
Mark Elias wins where's our Mark Elias
where's this guy oh the left is ballot
harvesting they're beating us about
horses where's the rights about
harvesting why doesn't the right Trump
said we're going to get really good at
it yeah Trump finally and I'm not gonna
be fine he did he came out and said he
quote truth to me uh on this and I said
because I said why doesn't the right
have is there
a distributed Nationwide network of
physical
congregations okay I'm giving it away
now physical congregations of
conservatives or people who are at least
center right that meet weekly perhaps
throughout the entire year in every
single state in this country that the
right could utilize for the process of
ballot collection yes and it's called
churches don't try to reinvent the wheel
ballot drop boxes in every single state
where it's legal period make it happen
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time